now there's light now
so welcome today we're going to be
talking about data processing and open
source in particular how Google is
helping shape the future so my name is
Francis Perry and I'm a data processing
infrastructure geek I love figuring out
the right way to take a really complex
and powerful data processing system and
make it extremely intuitive and easy to
use
good evening I'm James Malone I'm a
product manager here at Google I'm
fascinated by data because data is
everywhere I'm also really passionate
about open source software because I
think it shows what people can do when
they work together to collectively solve
really challenging problems what's
really interesting to me is when they
can work together both data and open
source so today we're going to talk
about the next generation of data
processing and we're going to go boldly
but where many have gone before with
mixed success what we want to do is we
want to lay out a meaningful vision for
open source next-generation data
processing we'll start by looking at now
challenges today the challenges that
exist today that should not exist
tomorrow well all then launch into
MapReduce and it's influences on the
challenges of today and how it sets the
stage for next generation data
processing tomorrow next we'll look at
solutions that exist inside of Google
right now that can help you solve data
challenges and finally we'll talk about
something that's new and exciting Apache
beam how Google can bring its experience
and work with the open source community
to solve next generation data processing
problems first let's create a foundation
let's frame the discussion of
next-generation data processing so I
work in Seattle and Francis and I were
given a template and the slides may look
somewhat familiar at this point the day
and I had one thought when I saw this
slide I don't have enough vitamin D and
I am definitely working in the wrong
Google office I absolutely want to work
there it's gorgeous
but if I were you what I would be
wondering is we're talking about
next-generation data processing what
things specifically what challenges do
we need to solve for in order to end up
in a space where we can say we are in
next generation data processing we think
there are three specific things now
infrastructure can sometimes be hard now
creating unified batch and streaming
data processing pipelines can be
challenging now the portability of those
data pipelines can be a real pain first
management now the emergence of open
source data processing tools that allow
you to process large amounts of data in
parallel the Apache Hadoop and Apache
spark ecosystems are a great example
they're both a blessing and a curse they
allow you to set up an environment where
you can decide on a tool you can read
the documentation you can get your
infrastructure you can then set that
infrastructure up you can set up your
tools but then you have to tune the
tools you often have to find experts who
can help you adjust all of the knobs on
those tools you have to production Eliza
your environment even though the tools
exist and they're awesome they're very
powerful and they're great to use they
can be very difficult and by the end of
the day you are probably now a team of
people supporting both infrastructure
and software when your end goal at the
end of the day was to simply process a
lot of data that's important to you but
next this should no longer be the case
in the future we think it should be very
similar to using a tool in the toolbox
you should be able to open a toolbox
pick out the tool you need not have to
assemble the tool and forge the iron and
tune everything you should know how to
use the tool intuitively or even just
watch a simple youtube video to get it
and then carry away and solve your
problem now the second thing that we
think is really important for the future
of data processing is the right set of
abstractions how you represent your data
processing pipeline right as data
processing needs to become more
sophisticated users often find that they
have to write a traditional batch system
for correct results and also use a
different stream
system to get more real-time updates now
this bifurcation means that you have to
write twice as much code you have to
maintain twice as much infrastructure
and somehow reconcile these two
different results into one conceptual
output now we think if we can find the
right way to represent our data
processing pipelines we can handle both
batch and streaming use cases in the
same unified system and the final thing
that we think is going to change the
future of data processing is portability
right many current systems tightly
couple the code for expressing your
logic with the implementation of the
service itself so that means if you want
to move your application from Hadoop to
spark or from on-premise to cloud you
have to rewrite large portions of that
logic and a different framework and then
you have to dive in and find what the
right tooling tuning knobs are in this
new scenario so we can break that cycle
again if we find that right abstraction
that right model you'll be able to write
your application logic once and run it
in multiple places so ultimately you
might be asking great so you've
identified three things management model
and portability but why do these matter
why are these things that you have
picked why are these the problems that
we need to solve for and what are the
impacts on me today and in the future
I'm gonna use a metaphor say you have a
rental car and many of you may have
gotten a rental car when you traveled
here you trust that the rental car
agency has managed the car you don't
have to pop the engine or pop the hood
and check the oil level when every time
you get a new rental car you also are
familiar with the controls of a car so
you don't need to learn a new set of
controls every time you get a rental car
and while you're traveling in the United
States most signs are relatively the
same and you trust that the car will
drive on different types of roads so you
have the portability you can drive on
the freeway you can drive on country
roads you can drive on city streets
there's no problems there ultimately why
it matters to you is when you are
wrangling with the infrastructure and
the tooling to solve complicated data
problems you are focusing on the
infrastructure and the tooling and
you're not focusing on what matters to
you the most your day
these are not new challenges and in fact
a lot of the challenges have existed for
quite some time they're really hard
problems to solve however so let's start
with a little history because MapReduce
is a solution to some of these problems
which has influenced the present and
potentially the future alright so back
in the early days Google like many other
folks needed to process a lot of data
however conventional tools and methods
couldn't keep up with the growth of this
data so engineers ended up spending
their time writing custom computations
to handle each particular use case now
if there's one thing engineers hate it's
wasting time right particularly on
something that can be automated so the
engineers started looking for a
generalized solution for specifying
logic that runs in parallel across many
machines at the same time they wanted to
shield the author of that logic from
dealing with low-level details like
moving data from one machine to another
and handling fault tolerance so Jeff and
Sanjay settled on a simple reusable
pattern right you take your data set and
you partition it into chunks then you
take each chunk and hand it out to a
different mapping machine a mapping
machine takes its chunk and runs a piece
of user-provided logic over that chunk
to process each element now each of
those chunks is processed independently
on a different machine so this makes it
extremely easy to parallelize once the
mapping machines are done they
redistribute their data across multiple
of reducing machines based on a key of
the data and then finally each reducing
machine again independently from other
reducing machines provides another but
runs another bit of user logic to create
these final outputs together this is
your output collection now the beautiful
thing about this pattern is it's
extremely powerful you can take pretty
much any big data processing algorithm
that you want and you can run it in
MapReduce you might have to take your
algorithm and completely convolute it
beyond any recognition but you can shove
it into that framework if you try hard
enough
so in 2004 Google published a paper on
MapReduce and at this point things
diverge a little bit
inside Google we kept innovating but we
were doing this in a relatively
homogeneous environment so we had only a
few file formats we were dealing with we
had a limited number of languages that
we needed to support and we had
extremely standardized tooling so this
meant that we got to spend our time
focusing on really refining our core
methodology and generating new ideas on
how we would want to process this data
so we continued to publish papers on
these new ideas and from the external
community folks saw a lot of PDFs
popping up a lot of good things to read
but nothing concrete that you could
actually get your hands on and play with
now at the same time the externally in
the open source community we had a
different implementation of MapReduce
inside Hadoop write an entire data
processing ecosystem developed here some
of this continued to be published by the
Google papers but there was also a lot
of new innovation that happened here on
its own in this very diverse system so
today Google cloud platform contains two
systems two products that come from this
MapReduce lineage the first one is
Google Cloud dataflow and this is a
fully managed cloud service that evolved
directly from MapReduce and includes
some of these later ideas from Google
like flume java's clean abstractions and
mill wheels focus on streaming and
real-time execution now for those users
who have a significant investment in
open source technologies already we have
Google Cloud Data proc which is a fully
managed service from executing Hadoop
and spark programs James thank you so
let's take a look at the first product
in the Google cloud platform portfolio
that's based directly quite literally on
MapReduce Google Cloud Data proc so as
Francis mentioned the Apache Hadoop
ecosystem evolved directly as an
implementation of the MapReduce white
paper and arguably it's had just ice I
apologize unarguably it has had an
enormous impact on the current state and
future of data processing it allows
people to solve really hard data
problems that weren't possible before it
has the models it has tools it has the
community it's really made a change and
how
people process data but a lot of these
tools also come with their own set of
challenges and this is true for apache
spark it's to think for Apache Hadoop in
general a lot of open source tools share
these three common problems first
installation they can be a real pain to
install and configure second they can be
really tricky to run at a cost-effective
scale third typically you have to know
quite a bit about all of these different
components to use them effectively well
google has been running MapReduce and
other data processing technologies at
scale for a long time so why not
leverage all of this existing investment
infrastructure and knowledge to create a
product well we did and cloud data proc
is the answer to that that challenge it
brings the familiar spark and Hadoop
ecosystem to the Google cloud platform
this is great for moving existing code
that you've already developed and
on-premise or other cloud environments
or brand new development and if you're
familiar with a sparking to do Pico
system there's a wealth of different
tools that fit into to that ecosystem
cloud data proc ultimately help solve
the thorniest management headaches that
usually follow the Apache spark and
Hadoop ecosystem it really focuses on
speed simplicity and cost-effectiveness
cloud data proc is designed as an
ephemeral solution and ultimately what
we mean by that is we want you to have
clusters when you need them when you
actually have work to do and we want you
to be able to turn them off when you
don't need them we don't want you to
have to carry excess idle capacity when
it makes no sense to you so we like to
think of cloud data practice combining
the power of Google both in software and
hardware with the power of open source
so ultimately what is cloud data proc
it's best to think about Cloud Data proc
is to top-level concepts clusters and
jobs cloud data proc cluster is
ultimately our layer cake of three kind
of big components the first cloud data
products built on the power of Google
cloud platform
this means the virtual machines that you
use for your cluster are Google compute
engine machines
you can connect to Google Cloud storage
so we use the already existing tools
available to us we then have an agent
that runs on top of this cluster it's
really the glue between the underlying
Google cloud services and the
open-source tools that live on a cluster
the agent is doing all of the things
like tuning the five to six hundred
different knobs that exist in spark and
Hadoop alone and finally we have the
open source tools this is spark this is
Hadoop this is hive this is pig
the second top-level concept in Cloud
Data proc our jobs and we provide a set
of tools which abstract the pain of
trying to manage workflows away from you
to create a an abstraction layer where
you can run some of the most popular job
types on your cluster without having to
open terminal windows or know how sparks
submit works which means you can submit
spark PI spark spark SQL Pig High of
Java MapReduce all without actually
having to ever log into a cluster you
can simply create a cluster in one click
and run your job in your second click
that's it
Cloud Data proximal SAR not isolated it
doesn't stand alone and this is a very
important point because it means that
you can read and write data to many
different places you can read and write
data from other GCP products you can
read and write data to data proc jobs
both on the same cluster or since it's
an ephemeral solution and you can create
clusters quickly any other cluster you
could also feed data to other
applications on the cluster so we give
you the ability to install other open
source components for example patchy
Zeppelin on the cluster Cirrus bark can
be talking to Zeppelin all on one
cluster easily I want to go to the point
about data proc talking to other Google
cloud platform products because this is
a very important point it allows you to
use the familiar spark and Hadoop
ecosystem that you may already have
knowledge existing code documentation
tooling and use it with the other
powerful tools in the Google cloud
platform portfolio for example you could
have a PI spark job which reads data
from Google Cloud Storage processes the
data with spark using PI spark and
potentially all of your favorite Python
libraries and then output the resultant
data set to bigquery
Google cloud data proc is designed to
bring the experience and power of this
very familiar ecosystem to the
integrated and comprehensive processing
platform provided by Google cloud
platform I want to back up some of the
things I'm saying and not just say that
Google Cloud Data proc is fast easy and
cost effective I want to give some
specific points to actually elaborate on
why that is the case so let's start with
speed on average cloud data proc
clusters start in about 90 seconds for
your average cluster they also stop in
about the same time that's really
important because if you have an
ephemeral cluster that you're creating
precisely when you need it it means you
spend less time waiting for your cluster
to become available you also aren't
paying for your cluster to start and
stop second clusters can be resized at
any time so if you have a series of big
jobs you can add more nodes when you're
done you can remove the nodes and Cloud
Data proc will handle all of the
brokerage and trying to Commission and
decommission nodes without causing your
jobs to fail we also don't bloat the
clusters so we include vanilla versions
of spark adieu pipe egg and a few other
components but we're not putting on
software extras that we think you might
not need which are going to slow the
cluster down or just complicate your use
of the cluster ease of use so as I
mentioned when I was talking about jobs
we provide a job wrapper which allows
you to send jobs to the cluster monitor
jobs you can stream the output of
drivers without ever opening an SSH
window you can do it in a browser you
can do it with Python you can do it with
any number of libraries you can do it
through a REST API that also means we
have several surface areas that you can
use to interact with Cloud Data proc
including our Google developers console
the Google Cloud SDK REST API s and at
the end of the day since this is built
on compute engine and it is vanilla
SPARC and Hadoop if you want to go SSH
into clusters go wild who totally can
and finally optimized for cost I have
never really met a spark or Hadoop job
which runs specifically to one hour or
two hours or three hours typically it's
a fraction or a subset of hours we bill
Cloud Data proc by the minute with a
10-minute minimum this means that if
your job runs for 28 minutes
you pay for 28 minutes not one hour and
when you're creating large clusters with
potentially tens or hundreds of nodes
this can be absolutely substantial we
also priced a cloud data product based
on the size of your cluster and the
number of virtual CPUs so it's easy to
understand and doing the cost
calculation is fairly straightforward
and finally you can use preemptable x'
and now custom machine types as part of
our GA last month that allow you to very
carefully craft the size of your cluster
based on the needs of your data
processing pipeline that means that you
can articulate your cluster specifically
so you aren't over or under consuming
resources so going back to the three
things that Francis and I are discussing
today but that are really important
problems that need to be solved for a
next-generation data processing Cloud
Data proc address is one of them head-on
management we have really tried to solve
the thorny management problems that
exist with some of the open source tools
so you don't have to worry about them
but there are other services in the
Google cloud platform portfolio that go
a little bit further and cloud dataflow
is one of them thanks James so let's
dive in to more details on cloud
dataflow now this is the past
the glut came out of MapReduce it is
based on a bunch of continued innovation
internally at Google now it's available
to you as a cloud product and there are
two key advantages to cloud dataflow the
first benefit is the programming model
this is the way that we encourage you to
write dataflow programs this is the way
that you represent your business logic
and you focus on that your application
logic not how you cram that logic into
some underlying infrastructure right
instead you're building a pipeline your
pipeline contains a mix of custom
element wise processing aggregations and
library functions dataflow pipelines can
process both bounded fixed sized data
sets like we're used to in traditional
batch systems but it can also handle
infinite streams of data and when you're
writing that application logic that
becomes your dataflow pipeline you don't
have to wonder about what type of
collection you're running over your
logic will apply equally well to both
bounded
unbounded data sets this means that you
have a lot of flexibility in how you
write your logic and it can be reusable
in many different scenarios now to truly
unify back and streaming into a single
system we need to separate the notion of
event time from processing time event
time is the time an event actually
happened so let's say we are we have a
mobile gaming application users are on
their cell phones all over the world
frantically doing something they're
popping balloons crushing candy I don't
know whatever it is they're doing it's
happening everywhere and we want to
process those points that they're
scoring and figure out information about
that so the time the user crushed the
candy that's the event time the
processing time is the time when that
score is available in our system for
processing ideally those would be the
same thing but distributed systems never
cooperate
so there's actually usually quite a
difference so here we've got a sample
data set of points that a specific team
scored in our game so on the x-axis you
can see the event time again this is the
time the point was scored and on the
y-axis we have processing time
so if distributed systems weren't
actually a problem right everything
would appear along this dashed line
something would happen and immediately
we'd be able to process it in our system
sometimes things aren't so bad so this
event here happened right before 1207
and but just after 1207 were it's
available in our system for processing
so maybe there was just a small network
delay other times it's worse though so
this event over here is 7 minutes
delayed from when it happened before we
can process it perhaps this user was
playing our game in an elevator or in a
subway somewhere where they had a
temporary lack of network connectivity
we had to wait for this user to
re-establish a connection before that
event was able to be ingested to our
system and processed now the margins of
this graph are nearly wide enough to
what to contain what would happen if our
games supported an offline mode now we
could have users playing our mobile game
transatlantic flight while they're in
airplane mode it might be hours until
the users land reconnect and those
events are available for processing so
as you can start to see these types of
infinite out of order data sets are
really really tricky to reason about
unless you know the right questions to
ask so the data flow model itself
revolves around four key questions the
first one is what results are calculated
what is that algorithm that you're
actually doing I'm computing sums joins
histograms machine learning models where
an event time our results calculated so
how does the time when each event
actually occurs affect your overall
results are we aggregate events overall
time for fixed windows of time or based
on bursts of user activity when in
processing time our results materialized
so that's asking does the time each
element arrives in the system and
actually get available for processing
does that affect results how do we know
when to omit results what do we do when
data comes in late and we've already
emitted the result and finally the
fourth question is how do refinements
relate so if we start emitting multiple
results because new values are coming in
and we're changing our mind what do we
do with each of those new copies how do
they interact so let's take a look at
and how we use these questions to build
a simple pipeline so here's a snippet
from our pipeline we are processing
those scoring results from our mobile
gaming application in yellow we see the
computation that we're performing
the first question the what right here
we're taking Team score pairs of these
scores that happened and we're going to
sum them per team we want to find out
the total score per team so right now
this is a pretty simple pipeline and
let's see what happens if we execute it
so in this looping animation you again
you see our our axes of event time and
processing time and that gray line
represents processing time as it
progresses as the pipeline executes and
encounters elements they're accumulated
into that intermediate stage
is white in white and finally when
processing completes we omit the result
in yellow so this is just how a batch
pipeline would execute it's pretty
standard but as we addressed in the next
few questions this is going to get more
powerful the first thing we're going to
play with is this notion of event time
so we'll start by specifying a windowing
function and by doing this we can
calculate independent results for
different slices of event time so we
could compute something of root for
every minute every hour every day in
this case we're going to use two minute
chunks of time and ask for a different
sum per team every two minutes so now if
we look at how things execute you can
see that based on event time we're
calculating for independent results
every two minutes slice of event time is
going to give us a different result now
at this point we're still waiting for
the entire computation to complete
before we emit any results and this
works okay if we're dealing with a
bounded fixed sized data set that will
eventually finish processing but it's
not going to work if we're processing is
seeing an infinite amount of data right
because we'll never actually complete
and and produce results so there what we
need to do is reduce the latency of
individual for the results and we do
that by asking for results to be
triggered triggered based on the
system's best estimate of data
completion we call this estimate the
watermark it's the way the system
estimates it at this point it's pretty
much seeing all the data it's gonna see
for this portion of event time so now
I've drawn the watermark on our graph in
green right and you can see that as the
results for each window passes the
watermark and we think well we've pretty
much got all the data we go ahead and
emit the result but again this watermark
is just a heuristic
it's the system's best guess about data
completeness and guessing in a
distributed system is going to be a bad
idea right now
the watermark is too fast we're moving
on before we have all the data so in
that first window we thought we were
done
then that user who's offline in the
elevator finally reconnects and we
realized we've got some late data and it
just gets missed in this case that users
out of luck their team is never going to
benefit from that score now we could be
slower and more conservative with our
watermark but if we do that we might
have to wait an unrealistic amount of
time so if we're dealing with those
offline users on the airplane we're
gonna have to wait till every flight
everywhere lands just in case there was
somebody in seat 26 B who is playing our
game right so that's not reasonable
either we need to be able to deal with
this type of heuristic best-effort
watermark and work around it so we do
that by using a more sophisticated
trigger so now we're requesting both
early speculative firings so as results
are trickling in
we're asking for tentative updates as we
go and also we're asking for late
firings or additional updates if we see
events later than we expect
so what this means though is that we're
going to be seeing multiple results for
that same slice of event time and now we
have to answer our fourth question how
do those results refine over time in
this case we're going to use
accumulation mode and just continually
accumulate the score so every time we
see new results will emit a new
cumulative sum that just continues to
grow now we go back to our graph and you
can see that we're getting multiple
results for each slice of event time in
some windows like the second we produce
some early speculative results those
data is still arriving then in every
window is the watermark passes we think
we've pretty much seen it all we emit an
on-time result and finally if there are
late results like in that first window
we might have met a late updated element
and because we chose to accumulate each
result that we emit includes all the
elements for that window even if those
elements were already part of a previous
result
so what we did here is we took an
algorithm in this case it was just
simple integer summation right I could
have taken a more complicated algorithm
except then I would have had to animate
it and these already got complicated
enough so we just did integer sums here
but it could be a much more powerful
chunk of user application logic and then
we tweaked a few lines and by changing
those other questions and addressing
them we were able to cover a whole
number of use cases we went from
traditional batch all the way up to
advanced streaming without having to
change anything about our algorithm the
what that we're actually computing so
just like MapReduce fundamentally
changed the way that we do data
processing by fine by just by providing
a new set of abstractions that allowed
us to reason about these types of
programs we think this data flow model
will change the way we do batch and
streaming processing in the future by
unifying them together based on these
four questions so that's the first
benefit of cloud dataflow the
programming model and the way that you
write your pipelines the second part is
the fully managed service for executing
these pipelines this service scales the
number of workers and configures that
throughout pipeline execution as your
data sizes evolve it dynamically
schedules work across your different
machines and it provides integrated
monitoring and logging so they're
between those two between the the model
and the fully managed service we've
addressed two of our three goals but we
still want to address portability that's
where Apache beam comes in so in late
January we took the data flow model and
the SDKs that implement it and we
developed these in conjunction with the
managed dataflow service but along with
some partners we took this programming
model and donated it to the Apache
Software Foundation as the incubating
project Apache beam which means among
other things we get a new logo so here's
our snazzy new logo with two overlapping
beams of light representing the
unification
back and stream into beam and now we
have puns all over we're beaming with
joy there's all sorts that the puns
never get old
alright but what does a battery beam
actually include right so it's the
programming model this idea of
describing your your data processing in
terms of the what where when and how
it's the initial Java SDK that we
developed as part of cloud dataflow and
they'll be other SDKs at other SDKs
including Python to follow and most
importantly for portability it's a
number of runners that know how to take
a beam pipeline and execute it on an
existing distributed back-end so right
now that includes runners that can run a
beam pipeline on Apache fling Apache
spark and then of course the cloud
dataflow service our goal as we
transition the dataflow programming
model into beam over the next few months
is to fully support three different
categories of users we've always focused
on end users these are the users who
want to write data processing pipelines
they want that nice little Pacman from
the beginning right where they focus on
their logic and their results they don't
have to deal with the other stuff right
they just want to take the language that
are already familiar with and run it in
whatever distributed processing
environment is most convenient for them
but in addition to those users now as
part of Apache beam we want to focus on
developing stable api's and
documentation that are going to allow
others in the open-source community to
develop new SDKs and provide new runners
for alternative distributed processing
environments so we're just getting
started growing that community so
building a community around Apache beam
is going to be absolutely critical to
its success the community will help
Apache beam really achieve the goal of
being an open source platform for next
generation data processing but building
a community involves a few key things
and we're just getting started building
this community first we have to focus on
collaboration we were really surprised
when we wrote the Apache beam incubating
proposal and submitted it
there is an outstanding amount of
interest in Apache beam there's also a
lot of groups that have thrown in new
ideas in ways that they want to expand
beam and see beam grow taking all of
this and collaborating together so we
can take all of the collective energy
and brainpower and needs and problems
that people want to solve and work
together towards a unified solution is
going to be both a challenge but
ultimately incredibly rewarding as
Francis mentioned the dataflow SDK and
model at this point has really focused
on end users we want beam through the
collaboration to also include the SDK
writers and the runner writers now we
want to grow Apache beam and there's a
few people that may be wondering why the
Apache Software Foundation it's come up
in conversations that I've had with
people here ultimately Apache beam is a
great fit for the Apache Software
Foundation because it will grow within a
community of other data processing tools
so as Francis mentioned there's a flink
Runner and a spark Runner it's not all
about just making an Apache beam awesome
and better there may be things that we
need to help out on with spark or with
flink or other projects and as a member
of the Apache software community and
under that umbrella we can make that
happen and that's critically important
we also want to learn and this is
Google's first data-related contribution
to the Apache Software Foundation and
we're learning quite a bit we're
learning the Apache way we're also
shifting from Google tools and
infrastructure to those that are used by
Apache projects and we're trying to take
that learning and apply it and learn
quickly and get started quickly and move
things forward so we wrote the proposal
in January and we entered incubation to
the Apache Incubator in early February
to show how serious we are about really
getting started and making an impact and
moving things forward
the first commit to the repository was
in late February so we're really excited
to get moving early in 2016 so where we
are now we're really focused on
refactoring and redesign we really
really want to folk
all three of those use cases so the end
users the runner writers and the SDK
writers that means by mid-year we're
going to take all of the design and
refactoring and things that we've come
up with new API so we're going to be
implementing them on the beam project
it's important to note though that we
don't want to and we will not interrupt
dataflow users during this process so
we're really focused on improving and
making these updates to the beam project
so towards the end of the year the beam
team can say that beam pipelines will
run on multiple runners who can take a
beam pipeline and run it reliably on
flank or SPARC you could also use the
beam SDK to articulate beam pipelines
and run them on the cloud dataflow
service so with beam and cloud dataflow
you start to tech check all of the boxes
for next generation data processing with
cloud dataflow you get an awesome
managed service where you can send it
pipelines and you don't worry about
infrastructure you don't worry about
spinning up servers you don't worry
about logging and monitoring with beam
you get a portable powerful unified
model that you can use to articulate
data processing pipelines so between the
two you start to end up in a place that
is truly next-generation that said well
we think that cloud dataflow is going to
be an awesome place to run beam
pipelines and we think it will be the
best managed way to run beam pipelines
beam itself is also portable which means
that there are other runners you can use
to run beam and these runners can exist
in any number of environments they might
be on-premise you might want to run
flink for instance on a cluster in your
local data center you might want to run
SPARC on another cloud that's okay these
runners may have varying levels of
fidelity and how they support being
based on their own models and underlying
semantics but again going back to my
comment about being a member of the
Apache Software Foundation that's why
it's very important for us to work
together inside of the Apache umbrella
so we can try and help everybody out and
move everybody forward
now it's getting late and if you only
remember a few things from this we've
been talking for a while if you wake up
tomorrow and you're like that was the
best presentation I've ever seen please
remember it with the following points
first the MapReduce paper in 2004 kicked
off a flurry of activity you had two
branches that predominantly emerged you
had one in Google that continued to
iterate on the ideas of MapReduce and
create new papers and then you had a
whole ecosystem develop in the
open-source community as a result of
these two branches we have two awesome
products that you can use today in
Google cloud platform to take advantage
of these work that work in these two
work streams you have cloud dataflow to
take advantage of all of the awesome
iteration and both infrastructure and
software they Google invested after
MapReduce and you have Cloud Data proc
all of those components you could use on
cloud proc today Apache Beam is a bridge
between these two work streams that
split in 2004 and 2016 we want to bring
them back together
Apache beam can be managed using
services like dataflow it's very easy to
run beam on manage services beam
provides a unified model for batch and
stream processing finally beam pipelines
are portable along different runners you
can take your beam pipelines and run
them on different runners in different
locations come on there we go
we hope this talk leaves you wanting to
learn more about doing data processing
and open source at Google you can go use
cloud data proc today you can start
spinning up Hadoop and spark clusters
and use that fully managed service if
you want to learn about the data flow
and now the beam model you can use data
flow today to write pipelines that run
on cloud dataflow and over time as we
finish bootstrapping you'll be able to
use a patchy beam to run those same
pipelines anywhere alright well thank
you very much James and I will be around
so please come find us ask questions
thank you very much
you